He for
[Silence]
The
continuing in the chapter regarding
repentance
mentions
a narration on the authority of Hubes
is one of the
he said that he came to a man named Ibel
to ask him about some of the rules.
rulings regarding wiping over the two
wiping over a person's footwear.
So
is the name of the companion
and
is one of the older companions. He has
very very few narrations in the books of
hadith. And when we see a companion who
has
many narrations as opposed to a
companion that has very few narrations,
this is not necessarily a reflection of
knowledge or a lack of knowledge. So if
we have a companion
who only has one narration or a few
narrations, a handful of narrations,
this doesn't mean that they
necessarily
do not have a lot of knowledge or did
not spend a lot of time with the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
The companion who has the most capacity
to narrate out of all the companions.
The most knowledgeable companion
hands down amongst the companions is who
who would this be?
Huh? What what do you guys think
you know people would would
[Arabic recitation]
good guess the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's wives but he has
companions
that were with him before he was even a
prophet the most knowledgeable companion
hands down is Abu Bakr Sudik
after that
both of which who have very few
narrations in the books of hadith very
few why first of all they died within
the first 15 years of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's death
number two they were the kat they had a
lot of things that they were dealing
with and there were other companions
that made themselves available able to
narrate hadith. However, Abu Bakr, he
passed away two years after the
prophet's death. Who was collecting
hadith at that time? It was all
companions still
passed away 15 years before or after the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam passed
away. Still collecting narrations was
in its infancy. The companions already
had these narrations and so
Abu Bakr has very few narrations. Omar
has very few narrations. Even though Abu
Bakr and Omar are so knowledgeable
that they have a sunnah from Allah
that is an extension of the prophet's
sunnah sallallah.aii wasallam. Meaning
that the prophet sallall.aii
am said in the well-known narration of
he said
he said I remind you all to hold to my
sunnah and the sunnah of my rightly
guided successors after me Abu Bakr and
Omar and man and Ali and Abu Bakr Omar
specifically in a sunnah the prophet Sam
said
he said follow closely the two guided
men after me Abu Bakr and Omar.
So these are the most knowledgeable
companions
of all the sciences of Islam. However,
they have the least narrations not
because of a lack of knowledge, but
because the circumstances were different
for them than they were for someone like
Abu. Abu
was commissioned by Omar
to be the muti and muadith of Medina in
his time. So his job all day, every day
was to do nothing but to sit in Medina
and
receive the students of hadith or to
sit in his gathering and give fatwa on
behalf of
and the
sobb
is one of the very old companions and
one of the first companions. However,
his narrations are very few because he
passed away very early
metab
came to ask him. He sought
out and he said,
"What has brought you, oh Zir, why are
you here?" And Zer said,
"I came seeking knowledge."
And so one said,
he said that the angels
do lower their wings
and bow their wings
out of respect and honor for the student
of knowledge,
in honor of what He is seeking the
student of knowledge.
The student of knowledge is
the person who is seeking
knowledge of the Quran and Sunnah.
Knowledge of revelation. What is
knowledge? Knowledge in the Quran.
Knowledge in the Sunnah. Oftent times
this is misconstrued. This is
misunderstood. This is misinterpreted
that when people read in the Quran or in
the Sunnah the word knowledge they
confuse it with anything that is
knowledge and that is not correct. The
Quran and Sunnah when the word knowledge
is used just that knowledge and it
is not specified as a particular type of
knowledge. It is only referring to
knowledge of revelation.
Knowledge of
[Silence]
defines knowledge and says knowledge is
Allah said and his messenger said and
the companions said because of their
knowledge of what Allah and his
messenger said. That is what knowledge
is. So when here says
that the angels bow and lower their
wings for the students of knowledge. Who
is the student of knowledge? The one who
seeks knowledge of the Quran and Sunnah.
They do lower their wings out of respect
and exaltation
of the student of knowledge
and out of honoring what it is he is
seeking. There is no
there is no honor greater
after
the prophets and messengers that a
person can be given than the position of
knowledge and scholarship. As long as a
person is
implementing this knowledge, not just
having it, but a person who implements
it, who
he implements what he knows. This is
what knowledge is in the Quran and
Sunnah.
Alhamdulillah.